a new game a new server that's been
shook
to its core by xqc and this time
his behaviors got him banned twice
xqc has smashed into the world of gta 5
role-playing and pissed off pretty much
everyone in it as if his combat logging
stream sniping and fail rp weren't bad
enough
he then crossed a line he could never
take back
these stories really don't come around
too often so make sure you are
subscribed to the channel if you haven't
done so already
and that way you'll never miss a story
again it's great
okay so to understand just how xqc
tormented this server let me explain to
you
the world that is gta 5 role-playing
almost anything goes in this world as
long as it's in the role-playing spirit
you can live out your wildest fantasies
on either side of the law
it's really important that everyone
stays in character
at all times and acts in a realistic way
the rules vary from don't drive at
unrealistic speeds to
you should fear for your life if
threatened with
weapons these rules might seem kind of
strange if you're not
part of this world but they're
absolutely integral to the whole thing
working these players want to immerse
themselves in
characters and narratives that they
would usually never be able to act out
in real life
and for them to do that everyone has to
be on the same page
xqc joined the very popular no
pixel server back in february which has
attracted
big streamers such as summit greek god x
and hassan
in rp your favorite streamers and
players will create a character by
giving traits
strengths and weaknesses whilst finding
their way through san andreas hello
and for the most part he did stick to
the rules
in his own chaotic way you tased you
missing
you try causing me escape me don't cuff
other officer cuff because you missed
caesar
no not me miss taste so when do i go to
jail
right now but then xqc started smashing
his car into people who were racing this
is also known as
vehicle deathmatch or vdm and in this
world
it's really not cool
are you doing
so to nobody's surprise except xqc's
this happened the next day okay yeah
they they banned me belly okay and soon
after that admin
whippy cleared up the specifics of the
band hey let me make this clear
axe is not banned alex jumps thank you
x was reached out by an admin a couple
of days ago
and he missed his message so
he's banned until he reads it that's it
after serving a two-day ban xqc was
reinstated
on the server and the havoc continued
in city business all right go go go get
it get it get it get it get it get the
[ __ ]
get the kid get in get it get it get it
get it done
although sqc's interactions with the
police at this point
were non-violent and pretty funny if i'm
honest
it was clear that the two were not
seeing eye to eye
put her down i'm trying to no kids stay
away he's gonna pick you up too
and when a cop seemed to purposefully
stall for time while driving xqc to jail
you could see he'd reached a breaking
point the feeling was clearly mutual too
favo anto is a streamer known as officer
andrews who was
asked why he didn't bother to arrest xqc
why because i don't want to [ __ ] hear
it that i really don't
i'm way too tired and delirious to deal
with nonsense
i don't i don't have the patience it
felt like a lose-lose situation for the
cops
they either had to put up with xqc's
irritating behavior
or slack on their role-playing duties by
just
ignoring him in real life cops don't
tend to turn a blind eye just because
they're
irritated by a suspect now that that was
happening
the role playing was starting to unravel
and as streamer cat fires found out xqc
was about to grab that thread and
pull it punch me punch i don't want to
punch you punch me i can't punch you
what did you do
i work at a daycare it had reached a
boiling point the slightest thing
could push this standoff over the edge
the next day
xqc was stopped by the police for
possession of a stolen car and he wasn't
too happy about it
unbeknownst to the officers as they took
xqc into custody
he used a known glitch by keeping his
gun on his hotbar he was able to conceal
it from the police
now if you know what xqc is like you can
probably guess
what came next while behind bars and
being read his charges
xqc officially lost the plot
okay you're looking at one count or two
riding one country
what the [ __ ] excuse me and it's not
surprising that officer andrews who's
also a cop in real life by the way
had had enough of xqc he had just killed
two of his colleagues that is not what i
say
we're not there in the discussion hold
on we let you [ __ ] cry for the last
[ __ ] two hours shut the [ __ ] up for a
bit
jesus [ __ ] christ while the calls to
ban xqc grew louder he began to take
shots
at other streamers on the server the
next day
he turned to hassan now hassan's
followers had warned him that xqc
was in the chat and might use what he
was seeing
to stream snipe him but hassan just
played the whole thing down
excuses my friend okay him being in this
chat is like me being in
tony's chat while he's playing he's not
gonna like use the information that he
gets
from us in this chat to go and like
and do an offline stream sniper or
whatever chat's calls grew louder though
when xqc tracked hassan down and then
logged out
during combat when the ambush failed
another
big no-no for role-playing when he found
hassan again
the accusation of stream sniping was now
heavily implied oh come on dude
oh come on okay dude
oh okay dude really yeah i don't know
how this goes
right yeah [ __ ] you hey felix
if you're watching suck my dick okay
there you go
hassan felt played but his chat felt
vindicated
especially when xqc finally admitted to
stream sniping
well i didn't i at first i legitimately
didn't and and they know that but then
then i i act at first
i didn't but then i did
things got nastier when xqc showed his
dms with hassan in which he accused him
of trying to vilify him
get help maybe i should have said that
i'm gonna get shut up i don't know maybe
maybe i should have said that i did it
anyway though hey we're going to tell
you from there hassan read out his
pretty reasonable and restrained reply
that xqc did not mention
but don't say i'm making you a villain
especially when i've been somewhat
cordial about it
also it's not the end of the world
between us because i know you're a good
person but you do turn into the content
golem when you're playing stuff like
this
xqc even admitted that he didn't read
that part
with all of this [ __ ] craziness going
on people
were really beginning to wonder why was
xqc very much
not banned well it finally came
the next day xuc was banned for a
second time from the no pixel server he
stated that his character had been put
on a cruise by the admins how long is
the cruise ship
uh i i don't know tickets is like up to
three days
maybe the ship either decided to take a
little bit of detour
or decides to um crash on the coast of
italy he then decided to join the
notorious ssb role-playing server
but quickly found out why they have a
reputation for being the
much rougher version of no pixel who's
going to who's in his vlog
he did not stay long at the time of
recording
xqc seems to be waiting out his no pixel
ban
in minecraft will he return maybe
has he learned his lesson who knows to
be honest this isn't the first time he's
done something like this
some of you will remember how we covered
him doing almost the exact
same kind of thing on a rust server not
too long ago
from alleged ddos attacks to xqc talking
mad
[ __ ] to stream sniping allegations to
multiple streamers quitting the server
entirely
apparently everything of course a large
part of all this drama
is just how big he is on twitch and
there's no doubt that a smaller streamer
with a
less devoted fan base would have caused
less of a stir
but that's for another video what it
really boils down to is that this
is what xqc does if you hate him you're
gonna just see this as yet more of his
disruptive behavior
and if you love him it's just more
content as crazy as this story has been
moist critical pointed out that this
kind of drama
always comes in cycles so i guess i'll
see you in the next one
he has 92 000 fans right now watching
him
and what was it 5000 came here to talk
[ __ ] to me
it's not like public opinion is against
him live stream fails is against him
and in a week they're going to be stuck
in his dick again it's the cycle
this is also known as vehicu i'm about
to say vehicular
from texas so get out of the vehicular
vehicle
with all of whoa whoa
where's your own board xqc was about to
grab that thread
and yank on it hard that's going to be
point taking out context isn't it
i'm just going to say yank it no i can't